[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de salud de
nuestro programa directo américa de
france 24 y para ello me acompaña ya en
el estudio nuestra crónica nuestra
especialista en salud más romeros a la
mar ya estamos a miércoles mitad de
semana y hoy precisamente se conmemora
el día mundial del trastorno bipolar en
qué consiste esta enfermedad mar buenos
días vamos a explicarlo muy por encima a
grandes rasgos porque ahora seguro que
profundizaremos mejor en este tipo de
enfermedad empezamos diciendo que es una
enfermedad mental y que en general
resulta una combinación de dos tipos de
episodios de estados de ánimo estados lo
que se llaman estados maníacos estados
donde la persona tiene mucha más energía
rapidez de pensamiento actividad incluso
también más irritabilidad y episodios
depresivos en los que pues se sienten
pérdidas de interés tristeza fatiga
pérdida de apetito por ejemplo también
estos episodios se van combinando
también dependiendo del tipo de
bipolaridad que sufra la persona y
además es importante decir que no nos
tenemos que imaginar que es algo que es
50 y 50 por ciento del tiempo sino que
es un poco distinto y además las
personas pues también tienen periodos de
equilibrio y normalidad y tranquilidad
según las cifras que se manejan en
general este trastorno afecta 46
millones de personas en el mundo al que
algunos recuentos lo elevan hasta 60
millones de personas hay una relativo
hay un relativo equilibrio entre hombres
y mujeres a la hora de sufrirlo aunque
pues los hombres a veces tienen algo más
de dificultad a la hora de acceder al
tratamiento al diagnóstico perdón y la
prevalencia se calcula que está entre el
0.3 y el 1,2 por ciento de la población
aunque como decíamos como veremos más
adelante podría ser que la cifra fuera
más alta precisó por el tema de los días
claro mari le quería preguntar qué tan
difícil o fácil es detectar esta
enfermedad porque además también usted
hablaba de algunos síntomas digamos y
pues no necesariamente tienes que tener
esos síntomas para sufrir o padecer de
este trastorno bipolar entonces cómo
aclarar también eso es como que que hay
que hace falta para determinarlo claro
denuevo decir que lo estamos
describiendo a grandes rasgos para
acceder a diagnóstico se necesitan cosas
mucho más maravillosas
pues por supuesto pero de hecho uno de
los principales problemas que afectan a
las personas que sufren el trastorno
bipolar es esa falta de diagnóstico de
hecho se tarda puede tardar hasta 6
años en diagnosticar a las personas y no
solo al acceder al diagnóstico sino
después de acceder a un tratamiento que
funcione también es algo que se puede
retrasar porque pues porque estos
síntomas como dices hay veces que se
pueden confundir con otros tipos de
enfermedades otros tipos de condiciones
también de problemas alrededor de la
salud mental por ejemplo en la gente
joven sucede que se confunde con
atención con déficit de atención con
ansiedad también con depresión por esos
episodios depresivos que contábamos y
eso es un grave problema porque una de
las principales claves a la hora de
tratar esta enfermedad es poder acceder
rápido al diagnóstico y al tratamiento
no de hecho no llegar a tiempo a estos
diagnósticos hace que los síntomas
pueden ser más extremos o que hayan
recaídas y pues también aprovechar para
decir que si se llega bien a tiempo y si
se accede a un buen diagnóstico esta
enfermedad se puede tratar acompaña
normalmente durante toda la vida pero es
algo que se puede gestionar se puede
tratar y se puede sobrevivir se puede
manejar marc pero porque hoy se
conmemora este día porque el 30 de marzo
pero este me hizo un spoiler en la
introducción del noticiero hoy pero es
que es que hoy es el cumpleaños del
pintor vincent van gogh en lacio hacia
169 años póstumamente se le ha
diagnosticado se cree que sufría de
transtorno bipolar y de hecho su
historia de vida también extrapolándolo
a una época muy distinta es un ejemplo
de lo que hace no tener un buen
diagnóstico de hecho o vincent van gogh
sufre mucha confusión en su vida
alrededor de qué es lo que le pasaba
hubo mucha incomprensión también por
parte pues de sus contemporáneos y
bangkok terminó suicidándose también a
raíz de muchas cosas entre ellas podría
ser no uno de los problemas alrededor de
las crisis de salud mental que tenía y
también es un buen momento recordar
entonces que él trae que la gente que
sufre trastorno bipolar puede tener este
15 20 veces más riesgo de suicidio que
las personas que no lo sufren entonces
pues también está la importancia de un
día como hoy para romper el silencio
romper el estigma y hablar de este tipo
de problemas y sensibilidades a las
personas y también respetar digamos a
todas las personas en sus diferencias
porque uno no sabe las luchas que está
batallando esa persona internamente marc
que ese conmigo porque nuestro segundo
invitado al día va a estar muy
interesante vamos a tratar por supuesto
este
[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado en día
profundizamos entonces este día mundial
de trastorno bipolar y para ello nos
acompaña en el estudio nicolás rodríguez
médico psiquiatra y director científico
de la asociación colombiana de bipolares
el doctor nicolás gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
muy buen día buenos dias muchas gracias
por la invitación doctor pues quiero
empezar preguntándole qué causa este
trastorno bipolar cuál es la causa
principal digamos si hay ok bueno
digamos sobre la etiología del trastorno
bipolar existe mucha controversia
realmente no se sabe cuál es la causa en
nuestro momento pues existen muchas
teorías de cuáles pueden ser esas
alteraciones si se ha visto que hay una
desregulación en algunos circuitos
cerebrales como la corteza prefrontal el
sistema límbico y esto hace que comience
el cerebro a generar una alteración en
ciertos neurotransmisores y ahí es donde
se presentan los síntomas pero la causa
como tal de que genere esa alteración
todavía es sujeto de estudio
entonces se ha planteado que es algo
multifactorial pero hay un componente
genético muy importante que viene ya
desde el nacimiento solo que es una
enfermedad que tiende a manifestarse
entre los 15 y los 35 años la mayor
parte de personas hacen las primeras
crisis aunque también hay personas que
las hacen antes de estar incluso
personas que las hacen en edades tardías
claro doctor queríamos aprovechar para
seguir preguntándoles sobre esta
enfermedad no qué tipo de terapia es la
que se recomienda para personas que
sufren trastorno de bipolaridad y que
ayuda a deben recibir precisamente estas
personas diagnosticadas porque partiendo
de que hay una divulgación a nivel
cerebral pero no es que sea una
desregulación permanente sino que por
ciertos momentos o periodos se activa y
comienza a darse esta cascada del 5 para
todos beneficio patológica que lleva a
los síntomas o las crisis eso es muy
importante porque hay que saber que en
la persona con trastorno bipolar no es
que todo el tiempo está en crisis sino
es solo por periodos de tiempo que es
cuando se aceptan de esta alteración
teniendo en cuenta que esa alteración
está ahí lg el tratamiento es
farmacológico porque uno busca como
regular esa alteración que está a nivel
cerebral y que el cerebro vuelva a su
funcionamiento previo pero qué pasa
aunque se parte de esto hay muchas
situaciones del entorno
manejo del estrés estresores vitales
académicos laborales familiares
interpersonales que pueden hacer que mi
cerebro vuelva a entrar en este
funcionamiento anormal y éstos serían
detonantes entonces el tratamiento debe
ir al manejo de los síntomas de las
crisis pero también identificar y
manejar estas situaciones de estrés ya
que si no las manejo bien eventualmente
también podrían llevar una crisis doctor
y marc lo decía se puede tardar hasta 10
o más de 10 años en diagnosticar esto
porque porque no es una enfermedad
digamos constante y por esos picos
pueden confundirse lo que realmente pasa
para un diagnóstico tardío a las
personas que sufren de trastorno bipolar
y que sucede digamos como esta es una
enfermedad que se desarrolla en personas
jóvenes muchas veces los primeros
episodios tienen una cara unas
características atípicas entonces muchas
veces arrancan con episodios depresivos
y se asume que es una depresión y sólo
hasta cuando ya hacen un episodio de
manía o hipomanía es que ya se plantea
el diagnóstico de trastorno bipolar pero
también es frecuente ver en crisis
severas que aparezcan síntomas
psicóticos como estas personas que se
salen de la realidad en tenerías
delirantes de persecución y eso también
confunde con otros diagnósticos como la
esquizofrenia y otros trastornos
psicóticos entonces a veces en los
primeros episodios
puede ser atípico y puede ser difícil
diagnosticar y sobre todo cuando llega
un paciente solo sin familiar que no a
como el context lado de cómo
evolucionaron los síntomas y también que
muchas personas frente al diagnóstico
tienden una reacción como de alejarse en
negación y eso hace que no sean
adherentes a los tratamientos ya los
seguimientos por psiquiatría o los
especialistas de salud mental claro de
hecho yo también quería preguntarle
imagino que eso puede estar en la causa
de este alejamiento que está
describiendo alrededor de del estigma
que pesa alrededor de la bipolaridad y
del peso que tiene esa palabra como la
usamos a veces en nuestro día a día sin
entender qué instalaciones puede tener
para personas que efectivamente tienen
ese transtorno que qué tipo de estigma
rodea esta enfermedad y cómo podemos
hacer para romperlo claro yo creo que
muchos de los estigmas vienen por
desinformación no entonces muchas
personas asumen trastorno bipolar
no es peyorativo es como locura o como
una enfermedad mental grave y digamos
las crisis si pueden llegar a ser
severas disruptivas pero fuera de las
crisis son personas con un
funcionamiento completamente normal
obviamente una persona joven que es por
lo general cuando se diagnostica que de
un momento a otro le dicen que tiene una
enfermedad que tiene que tomar
medicamentos de por vida y es una
enfermedad que muchas veces solo es
evidente en las crisis eso genera una un
rechazo frente a esto ya estas
condiciones y hacen que las personas les
cueste aceptarlo adicionalmente aunque
algo positivo de la pandemia es que se
ha puesto el discurso de salud mental y
se habla más de esto creo que eso ha
sido muy positivo pero antes no se
hablaba entonces cualquier diagnóstico
psiquiátrico ya sea sociedad con locura
o con incapacidad de resolver por mí
mismo mi situación es de día a día
situaciones adversas y eso hace que haya
mucho estigma también los términos como
bipolar o depresión se usan de una forma
incorrecta en el lenguaje común la gente
no habla de tristeza sino de depresión y
son cosas muy diferentes porque bueno la
tristeza es una emoción que todos
sentimos depresión es un estado mental
severo con tristeza inhibición y anidó
una pérdida del interés y muchas otras
cosas y bipolaridad son episodios
afectivos donde mi cerebro funciona mal
no es cambios emocionales súbitos o
repentinos que muchas veces el término
que se usa está bipolar larga de pronto
estaba triste pronto me reí eso no es
bipolaridad eso es un cambio emocional
que puede tener cualquier persona pero
el mal uso de los términos también
conlleva que hace aumente el stick claro
y que las personas como usted dijo sean
reacias como aceptar la enfermedad
porque además además a lo mejor dirán
también pues no son episodios que me
pasan yo lo puedo controlar pero
realmente si tiene una enfermedad que
hay que tratarla pero precisamente
también doctor el subsidio es un riesgo
grave en las personas que sufren de
bipolaridad por qué y qué se puede hacer
al respecto para prevenirlo o que esté
digamos es lo que sienten estas personas
con bipolaridad de respecto al suicidio
se disminuya o que digamos el suicidio
en el trastorno bipolar bueno hay que
primero que caracterizar que hay dos
episodios como tú decías que hay
episodios de manía hipomanía o de
depresión leve o depresión mayor
los episodios depresivos pues la
característica es una tristeza excesiva
unas ideas negativas sobre el mundo
sobre mi vida sobre el futuro una gran
dificultad para arrancar terminar
actividades y con base en ese
pensamiento yo puedo desarrollar ideas
de muerte no querer vivir más y en los
extremos de los episodios tanto manía
como depresión pueden haber psicosis la
psicosis depresiva tiende a ser
nihilista como de ruina de ellos en una
carga para el mundo para la sociedad no
sirve para nada y ahí yo puedo llevar la
estructuralidad de suicidio entonces es
un riesgo muy alto porque yo estoy
convencido de que todo está mal nada me
va a hacer cambiar de opinión y muchas
veces como una forma de aliviar ese
malestar aparece la idea de suicidio
entonces cuando uno ve personas en
episodios graves ya sea una depresión
mayor o una manía hay que hospitalizar
ya que el riesgo que la persona se auto
agrega es muy alto y en la manía más de
condiciones negativas puede ser que yo
como estoy acelerado no mide los riesgos
pueda tener conductas erráticas
conductas de riesgo y también llevarme
eventualmente al suicidio pero es muy
importante saber que en los extremos o
los episodios más severos la conducta es
hospitalizar precisamente por el riesgo
que hay de agresión auto agresión
sobre el tema de los tratamientos y
también alrededor del suicidio no es muy
distinto imagino tener esos pensamientos
nihilista sabiendo que uno está enfermo
que tenerlos sin saber qué es lo que
está sucediendo no que imagino que eso
es una diferencia muy grande a la hora
de afrontar o de como si atravesar estos
momentos que sucede cuando cuando las
personas precisamente entonces no saben
que tienen un diagnóstico no imagino que
además habrá muchas desigualdades a la
hora de acceder a este diagnóstico de
bipolaridad cuando uno lo tiene entonces
eso puede quedar este ser bad o puede
estar más expuesto al riesgo del
suicidio cuando una persona no está
diagnosticada claro y sobre todo que
hablamos nuevamente de la desinformación
entre mucha gente confunde la depresión
con
con desinterés con que es una persona
que no está comprometida o que quiere
llamar la atención y eso aumenta mayor
malestar porque me siento mal y tengo la
presión del entorno de que debería estar
bien y eso genera mucha frustración y
mucha impotencia y si yo no sé que esto
es una enfermedad obviamente voy a creer
que todo lo que estoy pensando es verdad
claro y si yo estoy pensando que todo
está arruinado que yo soy una carga para
la sociedad fue la idea de muerte puedo
aparecer como una respuesta y por eso
digamos lo que sí cambia el pronóstico y
mejora digamos la calidad de vida de
estas personas es un diagnóstico
temprano y si uno comienza a identificar
los síntomas que es que yo comienza a
estar triste a no dormir a tener ideas
negativas que sean ya varias semanas
todos los días claro o que esté
acelerado hablando más rápido durmiendo
poco que sean varios días que llegas y
esos son signos de alarma quería buscar
una consulta por psiquiatría por un
médico general de salud mental para
hacer la intervención que sea pertinente
en ese momento y un diagnóstico temprano
doctor para por supuesto mejorar la
calidad de vida es una enfermedad pues
digamos manejable que se puede regular
como le está diciendo más romeros y
nosotros cambiar nuestro comportamiento
ser más sensibles con las personas no
atacar tanto no juzgar y no usar
términos incorrectos a la hora de
referirnos a alguien por cualquier
estado de ánimo cambiante doctor
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo america marc muchas
gracias por acompañarnos estábamos
conversando entonces marc y yo con
nicolás rodríguez médico psiquiatra y
director científico de la asociación
colombiana de bipolares nosotros
continuamos esto es directo américa
[Música]